your dad used to be a working-class
neighborhood now it's one of the most
expensive and upscale districts in
Amsterdam the bloom cleft or flower
canal is lined with historic merchants
houses this is where Oliver Michelle and
George Gothel live the couple turned the
240 square metre living space here on
the fifth floor into a modern loft we
picked this place because it was
spacious it was also left untouched for
a very long time
it's from the houses from 1763 and it
been left open without any walls and so
we love the idea maybe living in a loft
in Amsterdam which is very unusual
during the refurbishment in 2007 the
owners kept as many of the original
features as they could
George Cottle is American Oliver Michele
is French their professional interior
decorators - what made me for corporate
clients but privately that tastes are
rather you could say on the quirky side
one of the things that we wanted to do
because the house was so big and open
because it is an old warehouse is we
wanted to divide the walls or the rooms
without walls using curtains and so we
created a series of tinted spaces within
the large warehouse to create bedrooms
and guest rooms that way they can close
off up to three different areas one of
the features of the houses we have this
beautiful view from the terrace of the
Vesta tauren Church here in Amsterdam
it's very famous it's near the N Frank
house as well so it's a very historical
section of town inside they've opted for
a mix of design of furniture and vintage
pieces basically it really is a personal
reflection of what we like and and it's
a real mix of found objects and pieces
that we've collected over time when
we've traveled around we've lived in too
many different places the u.s. the UK
Italy and of course here in the
Netherlands twice now so so we picked
things along the way
it's these souvenirs that give the
apartment its special Flair they found
this decorated skull in Mexico
the couple are especially fond of art
that features taxidermy and anatomical
models
if this sculpture is made of leather and
yarn some works are a little unsettling
some of the works are by Dutch artists
the objects we have here are really kind
of always kind of at the break between
beautiful and somewhat disturbing and we
we really like that tension so the house
is quite unusual in the sense that it's
it's it's a lot of pieces that are ugly
beautiful I suppose you could say the
apartment is so spacious that you never
get under each other's feet which is
just as well because they also work from
home
I think this is kind of little oasis for
us and we have a lot of pieces that
bring us inspiration that excite us or
that kind of you know make you think and
we're always looking for new things that
you know excite us or or really just
give us a new perspective on something
and they themselves have certainly
brought a new perspective to this
historic house in the heart of Amsterdam
you